[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, Special Relativity.
In this section, you're
going to take a journey
through our solar
system and beyond.
1977 marks the first flight
of the Voyager program.
Voyager is an MIT-led program
with the original mission
to study planetary systems.
Now, Voyager 1 and Voyager
2, two spacecrafts,
are studying the
interstellar space.
Those two probes are
still sending back now,
more than 40 years
later, information
about measurement of their
surroundings back to Earth.
Those are the two furthest-away
objects we were able to send.
What we have here in 8.20--
and it's IAP, so we are a
little bit more ambitious--
our mission is to bring
us to Alpha Centauri.
Alpha Centauri is the
closest star and planetary
system to our solar system.
It's actually not just one
star, but multiple stars.
And our journey brings
us to Proxima B,
which is a planet in the
Alpha Centauri system.
So we have a very
fancy spacecraft.
It's able to travel with a
constant velocity of 0.943 c,
speed of light.
The gamma factor is 3, and the
path which it's going to take
is 5 light years long.
Alice is our ground control.
She is going to stay on Earth.
And Bob is going to take this
journey with Virgin Galactic.
After some time, Bob is
going to arrive on Proxima B.
So your first challenge
is to now calculate
how long does this trip
take from Alice's and Bob's
perspective?
So I ask you to stop the video
here and just work this out.
So for Alice, the time
needed is 5 light years
divided by 0.9, by
the velocity of 0.943,
times the speed of light.
And that gives us 5.3 years.
So after 5.3 years, Alice
is observing Bob's arrival
on Proxima B. For Bob,
the length of this path
is Lorentz contracted--
5 light years
divided by 3, which
is the gamma factor, which
results to 1.67 light years.
So for him, the journey
takes only 1.77 years--
1.67 light years divided by
0.943 times the speed of light.
So apparently, the time
experienced by Alice and Bob
for the very same
journey is different.
So this now is the
first part, where
we enter discussions
of paradoxes
in special relativity.
And this will bring
us, ultimately,
to an understanding of the twin
paradox later in this course.